hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i have made
the
decision
to stop posting as much on this youtube
channel
i've set up a whole new channel and a
lot of people have been asking me
why have you done that why have you got
a new channel am i still going to be
posting on this channel what's the
purpose so i thought i had a obligation
to my subscribers to explain
what i am planning to do and why i would
say subscribe to the channel but i guess
it doesn't really matter anymore because
i got this new channel now but what's
happening so what's going on is i've set
up a brand new channel and the channel
is called
undercover millionaire now this channel
is brand spanking new in fact my very
first video is just going up like i
think in a few minutes time i'm
literally only going to be doing
financial freedom challenges
documentaries social experiments
giveaways kind of content like that so
it's going to be i'm going to put a lot
of time and energy into the channel i
would suggest that if you're a fan of me
and if you enjoy the videos and the
content i would suggest subscribing to
that new youtube channel and i will
leave a link in the description get down
and subscribe to the channel and i'm
going to be uploading on that channel
probably just like once a month or
something because it can take me a very
long time to do the videos
i mean the financial freedom challenge
is a week just of filming and then let
alone editing and everything so that's
what's going down so subscribe to the
channel am i terminating this channel am
i everything in this channel a lot of
people have been messing around on
instagram saying you know don't please
don't turn out the channel what are you
gonna do about when is wednesday and q a
sunday what's happening so with this
channel i'm not gonna be terminating the
channel of course um i am not gonna be
posting as regularly though on this
channel okay so historically for the
last like three years i've posted a
video every single day and i've been
doing that um every single day for years
and i'm not going to be doing that
anymore so i am still going to be
keeping this channel i am still going to
be posting on this channel
winners on our wednesdays
are still happening on this channel okay
also i'm gonna be doing q a sundays but
i'm not gonna be posting more than like
three times a week so i'm just gonna
post much less on this channel and all
of the challenges and the movies and the
documentaries are gonna be over on
undercover millionaire which hopefully
you will subscribe to right now and
another thing is this
i want to take some of the subscribers
from this channel and i want to involve
them in some of the documentaries in my
other channel like literally yesterday
we just uploaded the video where i gave
away 1 000 pounds cash in the streets of
london in exchange for a pound it was a
mystery box so they didn't know there's
a thousand pound in there and it's just
so interesting people's psychology but i
want to get you involved in that
financial freedom challenges the
eviction show where i take 12 people and
let them live with me for a month all
that kind of stuff is all going to be
happening on my other channel but i want
you to be involved i want you to
potentially be involved in the videos i
want to see you win i want to challenge
you so
right now go subscribe to the undercover
millionaire channel it's in the
description stay tuned for future videos
on this channel but just not as
regularly i look forward to seeing you
over at the undercover millionaire and
also check out the video that i just
posted tonight because it's just it's
the most amazing thing ever i'm
literally
trying to trying to sell the box to the
policemen and all kinds of stuff it's
hilarious go check it out i'll see you
soon i really appreciate every single
one of you peace out i just wanted to
get your advice on something that's all
right because i want to make sure i'm
not doing anything illegal or anything
like that in the area so i'm offering
people to buy my mystery box
no of course not in that case would you
like to buy my mystery box
i wanna ask is a pound
and i'm not going to rob a police
officer i mean that would be the most
yeah it would be
if you were out of uniform you would
as long as they have cocaine i'm not
even sure i don't own a bank
hell no